>> Sean: TONIGHT MAJOR PROGRESS
ON MULTIPLE FRONTS IN OUR QUEST
FOR EQUAL JUSTICE.
JOHN DURHAM'S INVESTIGATION
INTO THE ORIGINS OF THIS RUSSIA
WITCH HUNT CAUSING MASSIVE
PANIC.
>> Sean: YOU
>> Sean: NOT RANK AND FILE.
REMEMBER LAST WEEK "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" REPORTED DURHAM'S
INVESTIGATION PROVOKED ANXIETY
IN THE RANKS OF THE CIA AND
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
SPECTATOR TONIGHT MANY TOP
OFFICIALS ARE NOW RUNNING
SCARED AND FOR GOOD REASON.
2016 AND INTERNATIONAL EFFORT
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM AND THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
IT ALL OCCURRED.
MULTIPLE SECRET UNDERCOVER
INFORMANTS WERE INVOLVED.
ALL TOTALED AT LEAST THREE,
POSSIBLY MORE TRUMP ASSOCIATES
WERE ACTIVELY SPIED ON ABROAD
IN WHAT WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED
EFFORT TO SURVEIL ON A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
THAT MEANS THERE IS TONIGHT IN
AMERICA THE STRONG POSSIBILITY
THAT IN 2016 WHAT WOULD BE
ILLEGAL INTELLIGENCE GATHERING
AGAINST AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
AN AMERICAN CAMPAIGN WAS
ACTUALLY SUBCONTRACTED OUT TO
ALLIED COUNTRIES TO PURPOSELY
CIRCUMVENT U.S. LAW,
CONSTITUTIONAL CIVIL LIBERTIES,
HAVE THEM DO THE DIRTY WORK AND
PASS IT ON TO OUR GUYS AS IF
THAT WOULD BE LEGAL.
SO WHAT DID THESE TOP C.I.A.
OFFICIALS NOT RANK AND FILE, AT
THE TOP, WHAT DID THEY KNOW AND
WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT?
AT THE SAME TIME CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WITH RUSSIAN
LIES, MISINFORMATION,
PROPAGANDA WAS ALLEGEDLY BEING
PUSHED BY THEN C.I.A. DIRECTOR,
A GUY BY THE NAME OF JOHN
BRENNAN.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED ON OBAMA
AND SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE'S WATCH, NOT DONALD TRUMP.
BRENNAN A CONSPIRACY HATER ON
MSNBC.
HE SHOULD BE WORRIED TONIGHT.
I CALLED THE PRESIDENT
TRESONOUS.
FAR MORE PLAUSIBLE THAT IN FACT
IT WAS BRENNAN WHO USED HIS
HUGE POWER AND INFLUENCE AT THE
CENTRAL INTELLIGENCE AGENCY TO
SPREAD LIES, PROPAGANDA,
MISINFORMATION, TO INFLUENCE A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
HOW DEEP THIS GOES WE WON'T
FIND OUT AND IT IS NOT JUST
BRENNAN WHO NEEDS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS CULTURE OF CORRUPTION
AMONG THESE HIGH-RANKING
OFFICIALS THAT STILL ARE
SERVING IN OUR GOVERNMENT
APPEARS TO BE ALIVE AND WELL
ACCORDING TO THE TIMES, QUOTE,
SENIOR AGENCY OFFICIALS HAVE
QUESTIONED WHY THE C.I.A.'S
ANALYTICAL WORK SHOULD BE
SUBJECTED TO A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR'S SCRUTINY.
TO THE CREDIT OF GINA HASPEL
SHE WILLFULY COOPERATE AND
EVERYBODY IN HER AGENCY
WILLFULY COOPERATE.
I HAVE NEWS FOR THE SENIOR
OFFICIALS BY THE WAY, NOBODY IN
THIS COUNTRY IS ABOVE THE LAW.
NOBODY.
WE ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC BASED ON THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES OF WE, YOU, WE THE
PEOPLE, NOT THE GOVERNMENT.
FIDELITY TO OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
CIVIL LIBERTIES IS A
CORNERSTONE OF SUCCESSFUL CIVIL
SOCIETY.
NOW, WE DO ENTRUST WHAT IS
ABSOLUTELY, POSITIVELY -- I'M
PROUD OF THIS BECAUSE WE NEED
THEM.
THE WORLD'S SINGLE MOST
POWERFUL TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE
TO PROTECT US AGAINST MANY
ENEMIES BOTH FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC.
THOSE ENEMIES ARE REAL.
THESE POWERFUL TOOLS, HOWEVER,
ARE NEVER TO BE WEAPONIZED
AGAINST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR
OR POLITICAL OPPONENTS OR
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS.
AND MARK MY WORDS, WE WILL GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
JOHN DURHAM WILL UNCOVER THE
TRUTH.
WE'LL GET THE EQUAL JUSTICE
THAT YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE.
IT IS A SAD CHAPTER THAT SOME
PEOPLE WOULD ABUSE THEIR POWER
TO THIS LEVEL.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO
SPYING, YOU CAN DESTROY ANYBODY
IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTION.
WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
RULE OF LAW.
WHICH IS WHERE OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES COME FROM.
THE PRESIDENT, ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ARE ALL DEDICATED TO
STOPPING THIS ABUSE OF POWER
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN NO
MATTER WHO WAS INVOLVED.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CLEARLY BELIEVE THERE
WERE A GROUP OF PEOPLE WORKING
AGAINST YOU.
DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT OBAMA
WAS BEHIND IT?
>> President Trump: HE
CERTAINLY MUST HAVE KNOWN ABOUT
IT.
IT WENT HIGH UP IN THE CHAIN.
YOU'LL FIND THAT OUT.
I WON'T MAKE THAT STATEMENT
QUITE YET.
I WOULD SAY THAT PRESIDENT
OBAMA HAD TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
A PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION USED
THE INTELLIGENCE DATA AND
AGENCIES TO SPY ON MY CAMPAIGN.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE PRESIDENT
OBAMA SPIED ON YOUR CAMPAIGN?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
KNOW.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL FIND OUT.
>> KEEPING THE DEEP STATE IN
CHECK WILL BE A STRUGGLE.
OVER THE WEEKEND EVEN "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" ISSUED A REPORT
ABOUT AMERICA'S ESCALATING
ONLINE ATTACKS AGAINST RUSSIA'S
POWER GRID.
THE TIMES IS ALLEGING THE
PRESIDENT WAS PURPOSELY LEFT IN
THE DARK ABOUT THESE NEW
MEASURES, QUOTE OFFICIALS
DESCRIBE BROAD HESITATION TO GO
INTO DETAIL WITH MR. TRUMP
ABOUT OPERATIONS AGAINST RUSSIA
FOR CONCERN OVER HIS REACTION
AND THE POSSIBILITY THAT HE
MIGHT COUNTER AMANDA OR DISCUSS
IT WITH FOREIGN OFFICIALS.
EXCUSE ME.
WHETHER WASHINGTON, UNELECTABLE
BUREAUCRATS LIKE IT OR NOT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS A DULLY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE WAS GIVEN HIS POWER AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT BY
WASHINGTON SWAMP AND SEWER
CREATURES.
AND HE MUST BE BRIEFED ON ANY
SERIOUS SECURITY MEASURE THAT
THIS COUNTRY TAKES AGAINST AN
INTERNATIONAL FOE AND YES,
RUSSIA IS A FOE.
A HOSTILE REGIME RUN BY A
HOSTILE ACTOR BY THE NAME OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AS AN ASIDE I'LL THROW THIS OUT
THERE.
YOU WANT TO BRING RUSSIA AND
PUTIN TO THEIR KNEES?
THIS COUNTRY CAN AND SHOULD OUT
PRODUCE THEM IN TERMS OF ENERGY
AND WHEN WE DO THAT, AND USE
THE VAST RESOURCES THAT ARE FAR
BIGGER THAN THEIRS AND HELP OUR
ALLIES WITH WHAT IS THE
LIFEBLOOD OF EVERY ECONOMY, OIL
AND GAS, GUESS WHAT?
THEY WILL BE IN DEEP TROUBLE.
BUT YOU DO HAVE THESE HOLIER
THAN THOU JAMES COMEY SUPER
PATRIOTS IN OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL THAT HAVE TO BE STOPPED.
THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
MUST BE SERVED.
WE MUST BE PROTECTED FROM WHAT
IS A POWERFUL FEW UNELECTED,
UNACCOUNTABLE BUREAUCRATS AND
FOR MANY YEARS ONE OF THOSE
POWERFUL, UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS, THERE SHE IS,
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE A FALLOUT OF HER
MISHANDLING OF SECRET
INFORMATION IN HER TIME AS
SECRETARY OF STATE IS FAR FROM
OVER.
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID TO
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
BREAKING MOMENTS AGO CATHERINE
HERRIDGE IS NOW REPORTING AT
THIS HOUR THAT AN ONGOING STATE
DEPARTMENT PROBE HAS NOW
IDENTIFIED AT LEAST 15
INDIVIDUALS WHO MISHANDLED
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ASSOCIATED
WITH CLINTON'S SECRET SERVER
THAT WAS IN THE MOM AND POP
BATHROOM CLOSET.
THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT REVIEW
HAS FOUND 30 SERIOUS SECURITY
INCIDENTS AND THOSE NUMBERS
COULD GET HIGHER WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
A VERY SCARY SITUATION, WITHOUT
A DOUBT.
HILLARY CLINTON PUT STATE
SECRETS, YES, LIVES, METHODS,
SOURCES, IN JEOPARDY AND SHE
DIDN'T ACT ALONE.
SHE BROKE THE LAW.
IT IS CLEAR, 18USC793 AND TRIED
TO COVER IT UP.
SHE WIPED IT CLEAN.